con una verdadera demostración de
poderío en el día de la marina rusa el
presidente vladimir putin firmó una
nueva doctrina naval que sitúa a eeuu
como principal rival y estipula los
objetivos estratégicos de moscú una
ocasión para el líder del kremlin de
lanzar nuevas advertencias a occidente
[Aplausos]
y brindaremos protección con firmeza y
por todos los medios lo clave aquí es la
capacidad de las fuerzas armadas que
pueden responder a la velocidad del rayo
a todos los que atentan contra nuestra
soberanía y libertad basta mencionar los
últimos sistemas de misiles hipersónicos
circón que no tienen contra tipos en el
mundo ni barreras queridos camaradas la
entrega a las fuerzas armadas rusas
comenzará en los próximos meses y ahora
sí
desde la antigua capital imperial de san
petersburgo putin elogió al zar pedro el
grande por haber convertido a rusia en
una gran potencia marítima la nueva
doctrina naval rusa es un reflejo de los
cambios geopolíticos derivados de la
invasión de ucrania acusa a washington
de querer dominar los océanos del mundo
y cataloga la expansión de la otan como
una de las mayores amenazas que enfrenta
el país euroasiático
específicamente en las aguas árticas una
zona donde washington ha advertido de
una creciente militarización también en
el mar negro y el día soft disputados
con ucrania en el báltico y el estrecho
de las islas kuriles siendo esta última
una zona cuya soberanía es reclamada por
japón la doctrina destaca planes de
crear bases navales y centros de
abastecimiento desde el mediterráneo
oriental a la región de asia-pacífico el
océano índico y el golfo pérsico
el vasto litoral ruso de 37 mil 650
kilómetros que se extiende desde el mar
de japón hasta el mar blanco incluye
también el mar negro y el mar caspio